i remember one of my first times going
to the beach i had
accidentally checked in on my facebook
and that's kind of how i came out to my
family about being a nudist
i have been a nudist for a little over
eight years i've always been
interested in it i just you know fell in
love with it the sun and the wind
it's just great free feeling for me the
joy of nudism is comfort
and is people feeling welcome what was
my first
experience like my first experience was
fun
i didn't get naked i was there
with a friend's band that was the
entertainment and i was going to be nosy
it wasn't instantaneous with me i didn't
have enough positive
body image to just get naked right away
i found out through an online search
that there was actually a
new beach near me so upon a little bit
of looking around online i
actually found someone on craigslist
she was from out of state just was
looking for someone to hang out with
someone local so i went
my first nudist experience publicly was
actually a nude beach
sandy hook new jersey i went with two my
friends and actually they surprised me
and then once i already was there i had
all my stuff they were like oh yeah it's
a nude beach
so i remember having a moment of
thinking like do i want to do this
can i do this and so i like i was like
yeah i do want to do this and i'm like
i'm ready so i kind of emotionally
prepared myself for that
do people ever get excited i would say
this is probably
my most common question that i am asked
from guys yes there are situations where
that happens
if that happens at my particular camp
we would go find a board member
or men that we consider security and
those guys go address the issue
first of all i think people are afraid
they have more self-control than they
realize
so i think the fear is that oh i'll
totally lose control and then when
they're in the situation they're like oh
i don't feel like this is
uh sexually charged a lot of guys who
are curious about you know
going to the new beach or something like
that they seem to be terrified of this
happening
i'd say 99 of the time it's
not gonna happen we're never in a
situation where
us as women are ever fearful or afraid
our nudists mostly old men i have gotten
this question a lot
i would say that there are loads of
nudist old men
yes but that said that's not everybody
that's interested in it
from my personal experience kind of 50
50 if you spread it out between the
different types of places i'd say
nudists are not mostly old men that's
definitely not it
people of color there are not a ton of
us
but there are a lot i'm actually a
member
of a few organizations the first one i
got into is called the florida young
naturists
specifically tailored to the young
adults
we don't have anything against the older
crowd just trying to make the younger
people feel more comfortable
if you are looking at clubs with
memberships you're gonna see a lot of
the old men but if you're going to nude
beaches
if you're going to events if you're
plugged into some more social media
you know people are active people are
doing it are children
invited are they welcome to the events
or the different venues
yes nudism's roots was a family
recreational activity where you engage
with nature
you can be in a lake you can be hiking
you can be camping and you can do those
things with your family
my camp that i belong to is a family
resort
the pure essence of nudity anudism is
family-friendly nudism
i have friends whose daughter was born
into being a nudist
she knows nothing else there are lots of
adult
nude resorts but there are tons
of family resorts all over the us
so children are definitely welcome
have you become more confident after
becoming a nudist
definitely i don't think i ever really
had a huge
body issue or anything like that but
this
definitely opens your eyes into you know
meeting people for actually the people
that they are
i actually had wanted to do a publicly
naked thing for a while but i was
feeling like nervous like i wasn't right
at the right
spot with my body i know a lot of people
say i'll do it you know when i when i go
to the gym or when i lose the weight and
then year after year like i feel like i
never lost the weight i never got to the
perfect body
so i was like you know what i'm just
gonna do it with the body that i have
right now
there were so many people of so many
races
and so many sizes and they were happier
than me
and i wanted that what is the grooming
situation like
there's all of it there's manscaping
there's no manscaping i think that's
very individual
there are people out there who just want
to go full natural
as you came as you're born but there are
plenty of people nowadays just
completely shaved that was something
that i had worried about my first time
and i remember like wanting to make sure
i shaved everything because i just
thought that that was the default
and then i realized like you actually
don't have to do that i know a lot of
guys that are completely
like they shave it they wax it i know a
lot of ladies that shave everything and
wax everything
i also know a lot of people that are
hairy like bears
am i desensitized to nudity i'd say so
yeah
not necessarily like it's a bad thing i
think in a weird way i'm actually more
sensitized to nudity
in that i have a positive reaction what
happened for me is
you learn to appreciate everybody's
flaws just like you appreciate yours
america's very
hyper-sexualized so being desensitized
that is a good thing if anything
i feel welcome i feel happy i feel like
if i see nudity i'm like this
person is my new friend the only thing
we notice on each other now is if
somebody gets a new tattoo or a new
piercing or
or changes their hair because
that's all we got once you get into the
the regularness of it it's not a big
deal anymore at all
do i tell people i'm a nudist i tell
everyone
i do and i'm so glad that i get to be
able to my family knows
i talked to my friends about it we've
had discussions about it disagreements
yeah i think i'm pretty open about it no
issues there
i wear it proudly i encourage people
that don't have positive body image to
take a chance and try it out i have had
some weird questions
put on me you're like how could you do
that or what's wrong with you are you
deviant
people react mind blown at first
i have a daughter who's 31 who was not
supportive in the beginning
but by the end of year three loved the
mother that i become
i would say that most of my nudist
friends are i would say in the closet as
far as nudism
they don't publicly acknowledge that
they do it and some of them are super
passionate about it have been doing it
for years
how has being a nudist impacted my
dating life well
i wasn't really dating to begin with i
mean getting candid
haven't really had that much luck in
that
personally but um you know getting on
the dating apps and stuff like that i
included in my bio
i would say that being a nudist has
impacted my dating life
i mean i would say in a good way i think
it's definitely more of a struggle
now not because i can't find someone to
date
but being a nudist is not something i'm
going to bend on
it's better to be upfront about it than
just kind of
slip it in there afterwards i have gone
on nudist for states before
which are fun i think the biggest impact
is like you know i feel like since
becoming a nudist i would want to date
somebody that is a nudist also or at
least wants to do it
with me is it easier to date a nudist i
think it's easier only because when you
meet people that
aren't nudists men assume because i
like to take my clothes off and play
volleyball all the time that
i just want to take my clothes off for
sexual purposes and it's
so far from the truth what's the best
thing about being a nudist oh there's so
many
i actually would say the people like
it's fun to be naked by myself but i
would say it's actually the community
it's something that i never expected
i would say you know the freedom body
acceptance that comes along with it
honestly it's how they made me love me
i didn't love all of myself before then
when i first got out there i was worried
it was going to be so embarrassing
people are going to be staring at me
watching me and all that
not even close to being the case no
one's paying attention to you because
everybody's naked i've done nudist
travel
i've had so many fun nudist adventures
great stories
there's a lot of just like warmth and
acceptance and i think
that's been the most exciting thing i
didn't have
positive body image prior to becoming a
nudist i thought i did
it's my joy i love all of me you know
there's nothing to worry about
there's no reason to be apprehensive
about it there's just
try it out if you're thinking about it
[Music]